foreign
[Music]
to welcome on for their first appearance
on behind the screens Jas and John Kirby
jack spot is probably if you're
listening and know what that is that's
where you know them from if you don't
know what that is we're definitely into
it thank you for joining me guys
hey thanks Ian uh so I'm Joss uh
creative Xbox
um
and this is John Kirby uh consultant
yeah thank you so much for having us on
of course so
um just really quick and you guys have a
great presentation on here and it's
going to be super informative she talks
to me a little bit about kind of your
individual backgrounds and um any people
want to know about you or how you got
into markets and uh developing this tool
yeah so for the longest time I was
really like a I guess a fundamentals
investor or swing Trader
um and then covet happens
and I think I like a lot of other people
got really interested into well options
and day trading
um and then I remember discovering an
indicator called nope
um created by Lily and it was an
indicator that looked at net Deltas on
spy options uh specifically to look for
reversions and and price action
um so that was kind of my first foray
into like market microstructure and then
from there I started learning about
Gamma especially through squeeze metrics
um and then for a bit I was trading
using spot gamma's uh levels where they
would put up levels pre-market and then
I would trade off those and then for a
time I was I was wondering what an
intraday uh gex structure would look
like
um and so I created guest spot and then
that's kind of morphed into this whole
thing that
um I'm pretty surprised and excited to
share with other people
um but yeah it's been quite a journey
yeah I mean I I came at gex from a
completely different angle because my
oddly enough uh I first started trading
uh kind of recently like four or five
years ago but I started off directly
with uh selling premium and um I
commented from I came at it from more of
like an academic side and so I was super
interested just in managing my Greeks uh
like managing an overall portfolio of
selling premium and that eventually
started to morph into trying to look
into where other people were positioned
um and what their exposure was because I
knew how I was modifying my own exposure
um and then especially as zero DTE
options started to get introduced and we
start to see these effects and we'll
talk about this a little bit in the
presentation but the effects started to
become more drastic so to speak I
started to really dive in a little bit
by means the bear trap Discord but then
also squeeze metrics also spot gamma I
mean all the resources that are out
there and then eventually I sort of got
to the point where I was like well you
know what I would rather do this my own
way and plug into talk the numbers
myself
and that's uh I met Jazz actually online
through his server NFA
um and we just started collaborating on
all these sorts of different research
projects and uh to be honest I think we
do more research than trading now so
um isn't that funny how that goes you
start to get really into the thing
that's gonna help you with your trading
and then you end up doing more digging
into uh the background of it than
anything else oh yeah it's fun I mean
the rabbit holes are endless right like
you get to really dive deep into things
um it's like it's like a combination of
both math but then a lot of it is human
psychology too that can get factored in
um which is always really fun
yeah and I think we complement each
other really well because Jasper is more
of like a technical trading background
he understands you know volume profile
uh or sort of the I guess Market
internal is a little bit better and and
I sort of have more of a background in
option positioning and options pricing
theory that sort of stuff so yeah it
works pretty well
it's really cool now as far as gex goes
like
um you know I mentioned this to you to
you guys already but from my side as far
as day trading working with a lot of
intraday Futures Traders uh I hear
people mentioning gecks like once a day
now so for those like unfamiliar can you
just give like a brief you know Overlook
of the concept
yeah yeah this is this is a little bit
uh my Camp it the I think the easiest
way to understand gex right without
getting into any of the math uh is just
that uh it is the easiest way to
represent the Tipping Point at which an
option seller will suddenly will have to
start to panic
um because their obligation has grown
too large for them to handle
um and and that's because obviously like
options on like Futures are instruments
with convexity uh if you are uh as soon
as you enter an obligation you sell an
option in particular you can be exposed
to a loss that is much more substantial
than the uh initial premium that you
collected and so that allows us to see
or see in advance a lot of the times
um inflection points in the market
yeah I think from like a from a Futures
perspective or at least an intraday
perspective too
um at least for me gagspot has been
about
um I I think this is a concept pretty
familiar to order flow Traders but the
idea of like trap Traders right so
people who are trapped in their
positions and are forced to get out
um you know we can look at that in like
the footprint or volume profile
um and gexbot is just a way of looking
at the options Market side of that so
where where are these pressure points at
which
um people are really threatened to close
their positions or press the other way
um it offers these pivots where you can
enter and keep tight risk if you're
looking for reversions or or breakouts
yeah I think that's the biggest
component for me and what really clicked
when you know I first talked to you guys
was
um kind of the the concept of trap
Traders right so and that's always made
sense to me because kind of like you
Jess everything from my side previously
is profiling and
um order flow analysis and stuff like
that and so you know this information
started to make a lot more sense to me
once I saw it you know
um but before really before I started
talking to you guys I had no idea I just
saw people tweeting about gex right so
yeah I think it's been around for a
while I know that 0dt has become like
this huge thing lately but I mean you
know spot cam was around since like 2018
um squeeze metrics for I think around
the same time maybe longer
um this phenomenon has definitely been
uh pretty common although I think with
like the bear Market of 2022 the
uncertainty you know markets become more
Technical and range bound as opposed to
like you know if if you're in a full
send Trend bull market there's not
really a point in trying to like scalp
ranges and just buy and hold and or
swing positions instead of you know
trying to scalp around in small ranges
definitely
definitely well cool
um I was gonna say yeah if you want to
pop to
uh
you know if you want to get into this
yeah yeah the reason that we included
these these two slides at the beginning
is just so that we can kind of all have
an understanding of why this is so
important
um and this is just from sibo and it's
just basically looking at stock uh
like at uh average daily option volume
um in indexes and ETFs and how it's
grown so much over time
um and the other thing to understand is
that because an option right is a
leveraged instrument
um even a like even a slightly
even a volume of options that's around
I'd say like 1 50th of overall volume
transacted shares is going to get you a
huge huge effect in terms of those
options having an effect on the
underlying uh on the underlying
instrument
um and that's what we've been seeing and
uh in particular with would you go to
the next slide too uh with the growth of
zero DTE options volume
um so usually what happens
um and kind of a lot of times the
missing link right is that if you buy an
option or you sell an option you're not
buying or selling it in a vacuum right
there's somebody on the other side of
that trade who's going to have to
compensate for whatever it is that you
did a lot of times people refer to these
entities as market makers I think it
doesn't necessarily matter it's just a
question of understanding what's going
into and coming out of the market so if
you buy a call you're expressing a
bullish bias you're getting along a
certain amount of um what we call like
synthetic or imaginary shares which we
usually refer to as Deltas
um and then that as with any order
rather or in order for actual shares is
going to have an impact on the market
um and so especially with zero DTE
um because those options are such such
short duration the effect of
um those Deltas are being expressed sort
of immediately right it's it's an
immediate purchase of shares so to speak
uh or selling of shares depending on
what happens
um and so it has a tendency to really
really move the markets and because of
the leverage effect uh because of the
fact that
um a single option which doesn't cost
you a lot in premium terms uh is an
expression oftentimes on average
somewhere around you know uh 20 to 50 to
100 shares
um at the top uh it's actually they
could have a really really outsized
effect on the market
um
yeah so that's just we just want to get
those two slides in so that people can
understand why this is actually or how
the effect has been growing and why it's
so important
um and then you can kind of start to see
uh See it in real time uh by watching
get spot which we're going to show later
yeah
cool
yeah I think with these
um you know to note that
with how short jaded these options are
you know a great deal of that reflexive
effect on the underlying is
um through gamma I mean that's that's
where most of uh it seems to be the best
way of measuring that those reflexive
effects
um
yeah makes sense yeah yeah
go ahead John sorry no no I just want to
say that the reason for that is because
uh gamma is the expresses the rate of
change of the Delta with respect to
underlying price so what that means like
tldr is just
um uh whenever your option is at Max
gamma it's that's typically when it's at
the money uh as it's getting into that
point that's when it expresses the most
risk for whoever sold the option for
whoever's on the other side of that
trade
um which is why waiting everything
according to gamma gives you some some
very sort of useful nodes in the market
because you can tell where people are
going to have to be panicking the most
um because it's essentially right if I
sell you an option and it's a 30 Delta
um as price starts to move to the strike
price at which I sold you the option
that option is going to move from a 30
Delta to a 50 Delta um but the ramp up
from the 30 Delta to the 50 Delta
um is actually that's the fastest part
of the curve so to speak so it's the
part of the convex city that is the most
convex in other words and that's when
people really get scared uh that are on
the other side
yeah and that's when you start to have
to see people hedging and making moves
to either cover that or get out or add
more in some cases I would imagine right
yeah a lot of times they we've been
seeing that lately a lot of times
they'll just double down
um which is interesting to see uh and
then get run over
of course so this is what we have up now
this is an overview I'm familiar with it
as well and you've got it on the Zero
DTE
part here and this is SPX right so at
the moment that's what it's focused on
yeah so this is SPX
um essentially what we do is we get the
gamma of each contract at each strike
this is zero DT only we're calculating
the game exposure for each contract for
both calls and puts and then we're
netting the difference out so we're
seeing that there's a greater amount of
put gamma along this side and then um
remounts of of call again at that spot
uh one one important thing too is that
for gexpot
um we are making the Assumption of all
puts being bought and all calls being
sold which leads to uh dealers being
short puts I.E short gamma and then on
the other hand uh they're long gamma for
for calls
um and in this case it's
part of the Assumption is the idea where
SPX is primarily used for hedging by
institutions
um but I think in terms of cons thinking
about it as a Trader it's more important
to
um it's really just about
differentiating between put and call
gamma that's really the reason that um
we kind of have that opposite for
display purposes
um seeing these these levels
um but yeah so the way this works is
that uh you know we have the guests for
each strike the pink bars is the gaxby
volume and then the red bars are gecks
by open interests uh and then what we're
doing here too is we're sort of
interpolating this curve and then this
is our major positive or major call
gamma points this is basically just the
peak of this curve and then our major
put gamma is down here which is the peak
of this curve which is the absolute
minimum
and the in between we have zero gamma
which is sort of a neutral point between
these these two levels
um and because so it's a price letter
style so there's no concept of of time
and so we use dots essentially to inform
uh prior states of guides for each
strike
got it so as the Market's moving towards
you can probably assume to see more
gecks approaching and then away pulling
off like so the white line and then is
your spot price right yeah yeah
um so this is the original form well the
original form is really our Twitter
image outputs
um and then it became this website uh
but I think it's actually most clear
um I ironically really recently
um was I able to plot this directly to a
Sarah charts chart book
um and you know even for me this is this
has been pretty new to be able to see
this in in real time uh the way that
that price will react to
um these levels
um so here I kind of show an example of
what a breakout trade might look like I
don't know how visible this is if I go
full screen can you guys yeah okay full
screen that's awesome yeah
okay so on the left here we have a it's
a 5k tick chart
and then we have the gex uh profile
plotted to it and then this is a volume
profile this is a uh 300 well this is a
yearly volume profile essentially and
then on the right we have a five minute
footprint chart
um
and so when I'm looking at gex I'm never
looking at it by itself I'm always
looking at it in the context of you know
auction how's the auctioning going what
is our volume profile look like then
does the option Market agree is this
also a point where I should be paying
attention and then you know drilling
further down what does the footprint
look like what is the actual
um order flow look like on a micro level
right
and so here uh just to set the stage
um we've kind of come up into this High
we've sold off we've bounced off this
major put gamma level and then now we're
kind of compressing into this upper
range
um and so typically you you have you've
two choices here right so like when
you're coming in the coming into the
upper end of this distribution
you can either look to fade it right
you're looking for a reversion or a
rejection or you can look for a Breakout
um how
based off of how we've been moving
um I would for favor a Breakout
just because as we were compressing into
this high volume node at 53 we're seeing
continue two-way action on Footprints I
know that this is a point I wish anyone
who's trying to short these calls is
going to be most threatened so this is
where they're starting to get squeezed
right this is where the glass sellers
are starting to get squeezed and have to
do something right yeah exactly
um and the fact that we can see like
very like strong amounts of volume here
shows that you know people are looking
for pressing into these into this
position and they're they're looking to
break them essentially
um you know if you're looking for a
rejection you'd probably see like an
instant failure or something but we're
we're doing this methodical pressing
into into this level so for breakout
Traders
um
you know typically it's like you look
for the pop maybe you look for a retest
and then you're you can keep your stop
very tight or you can you know
trade information for that
um go in early depends on how you like
to play it
um but these are these are the moments
where I'm usually looking for some sort
of uh a Break
um but even then you know with with this
gex profile I'm I'm always trying to
confirm with volume two you know I'm
looking for that thinness that pop
through the swing
and then the confirmation yeah so it's
all still like within the context but
it's obviously helping you visualize too
that we are this huge major positive as
well yeah yeah that there's there's
Confluence
um going on with this yeah but yeah this
was the 17th and then we ended up
breaking away
um a lot of it too is very much like
so like the gex profile will look a
certain way
um but if there's not like the
underlying volatility in the market to
give you those opportunities like it you
you can't like force it right yeah it's
um it's very dependent on like still the
underlying and and the context of what's
going on too I think another thing to
add Jasper is that in this particular
case we could see that the the bars on
the upper two strikes are expanding
which means that it seems like people
are actually adding calls above spot
which is what you want to see right in
the same it's people pressing for
continuation essentially yes
foreign
it's very similar to volume profile you
know except the difference is that you
know the following profile we can only
really see locally what's going on and
maybe you might be looking at like the
limit order book
um but those can always kind of be
spoofed
um but with with gex it's these are like
real positions that people are opening
with with contracts yeah yeah that's
that's high that amount of context is
well I think extremely helpful in my
opinion because you know for me as a
Trader if I don't have that gex overlay
like same thing I might be looking for
the breakout or a version and maybe
other context clues could help cue me
into a breakout but then having you know
that added call exposure above right
um yeah you know that people are putting
their risk on there as opposed to I mean
I don't know I still like looking at
limit order books sometimes but it's
it's so hard to like really judge it you
know like sometimes you'll be like okay
I see this this order up there but it's
probably just a stink offer like I don't
really know if it's real or if he's just
messing with with us or yeah yeah if
that's going to be pulled right as soon
as the market gets within you know a
point right yeah they just won't pull
you
um but yeah so this is another this is
the opposite or this is a different kind
of trade
um with gex now in this case
so there's also a
well I'll talk about that in a second
but right here we've like come into you
know we've rejected off the overnight
distribution uh we're coming down
we're sort of bounding around zero gamma
um and it looks like we're about to
explore this this lower distribution
area
um
and so here so there's kind of this
initial you know major put gamma the
this peak of convexity here
um but like I said before uh you know I
always want to look for that Confluence
and in terms of the volume profile
um I don't I don't have a daily
reporting profile here but I know that
this is the middle of this distribution
right this is not really where I kind of
want to look for
um if I was looking for a reversion this
is not really one where I want to enter
a position
um you know even for
you know adding to a short for
continuation it's not really the most
ideal place
on the other hand so we're seeing like
the gecks sort of reflexively um adjust
here and it's kind of flashing around
this area too which is a bit more ideal
if we're looking for some sort of
reversal
um
but yeah
yeah that makes sense too because you
don't you know same thing with the
context like you don't where there's the
most volume is probably not your area
where you're gonna try to put on a trade
anyway
um but as you can start to see that bill
below like as we're watching this you
know
um you can see that build below and
build
major negative yeah yeah it's sort of
like uh you know like
when you're targeting areas if you're
charting like like vpocs typically form
good
um targets but not necessarily entry
points because you know entry points
it's like your your odds or your
probabilities of whether that forms the
bottom or a top is is a little bit more
balanced not quite as skewed versus like
a low volume area over here maybe not
quite an LVN but um
you know definitely a lot less uh
quote-unquote liquidity right
yeah yeah that's another thing to note
right it's that a lot of times just
having the having get spot up can give
you a pretty decent idea of you know
what is the market expecting in terms of
the maximum move right because if like
major negative and major pause uh major
positive gamma are often those points
where people are still willing to buy or
transact those options and then further
out they sort of start to die off a
little bit so it's like those guys are
still worth transacting because there's
still a chance that we get there
uh but far beyond that is not highly
probable
yeah and there's also another case here
too like you know at first we're kind of
like scraping down and and this is also
a 5k tick chart
um but as we're coming through here
prices is dramatically speeding up so
there's like a reflexive nature of of
people at maybe adding to shorts or bids
stepping out of the way
um but you know when you're looking for
if you're looking for reversals right
like
um it's often the faster that price
moves that the odds of reversal get
higher and the other case when we were
looking at that breakout there was kind
of time for price to sort of compress
into that level whereas here like you
know say if you had shorter near the
overnight high or like even around zero
Gamma or somewhere
um the speed with which your position
has gone green is literally compressing
your brain and so like your ability to
make decisions has fallen off
dramatically and it's it's very easy to
uh get scared out of your position yeah
through the Euphoria right yeah it makes
sense and on the breakout side you know
when you're you mentioned it it kind of
has a lot of time to coil you know it's
like running a car up a hill is the
common thing right like sometimes car's
not going to make it up the hill the
first go but it's got to go back down a
little bit and then wind up again and
kind of break through whereas on this
like you know like you said yeah this is
if you start down your panic mode a
little bit on a quick quick yeah it's
like real time and it's like you know
the second one you see one person
covering their short it's like okay all
right I'm getting the hell out of Dodge
too and you get that that Cascade effect
whereas everyone you know and so we also
hit like you know if you were in these
puts this is sort of the the belly of of
the curve like the peak of your your
convexity right because you're so
strapped for time uh with both zero TPS
but in general with gamma
um so that you know any any point at
which you've hit that that that
geek is usually in the ideal time to get
the hell out of your yeah that's that's
an awesome Point Jasmine that like ties
ties into what I said at first like in
the same way as Peak convexity is the
highest risk for uh the option seller
it's also probably the time at which if
you're an option buyer you want to
liquidate because you're not getting
more convexity if you hold that option
longer so either if you want to stay in
that position maintain your directional
bias you should probably roll the option
further along out on the chain to to get
the that maximum bit of convexity
um or you should just liquidate and look
for another trade which is what drives a
lot of this action
yeah that's me the one liquidating
looking for other trades
I mean in this market you know it's like
you you take your points and you run
like yeah it gives you what what you can
we can take and then just get the hell
out because it's so uncertain for for
everyone yeah it's uncertain and until
pretty recently it was pretty compressed
too so you know you gotta grab what you
could yeah
I mean we finally broke out to what over
4 200 but yeah came back into the range
and it's just you can feel like the the
frustration of everyone
yeah you can feel the tension of it uh
while we're on this too like so
obviously we watched the breakout and
then a reversion right now when the
market tends to be very flat obviously
I'm assuming that it's sort of hovering
around that zero gamma value is that for
you guys an indication of like hey maybe
today is just not a good trading day or
are you still looking for maybe
reversions or some type of play out of
that
yeah it's it's so like
you know those days where we're kind of
just ranging around so zero gamma will
usually float around like the daily UV
Park and then there's like this you know
defined one of the same above and below
um I I don't know personally I I've I'm
a big fan of of trend days I know that
they're not as common as range days but
I find that like reducing the number of
Trades reducing the amount of risk that
I'm putting in at a time is is like
better mentally
um and the return the same way yeah
typically better
um so I like it definitely it still is
good at navigating the structure and
those kind of slow range days but I I
personally am just not really a fan
although I know that some people you
know really like those ones better
because you have your defined levels I
was gonna say I'm the odd one out here
because I I love this particular type of
structure
well it's what's what's beautiful about
it okay just to just to play the other
side is yes your trading frequency is
increasing more commissions all that
stuff but on the other hand what's super
cool uh from a gamma perspective is you
have the calls decaying up top and you
have to put sticking underneath and as
we go into the end of the day but both
of them will be kind of decaying equally
so as we get into one side it's actually
going to push us right back to the
middle and then we get to the other side
and it'll push us right back to the
middle again so you're kind of trading
with like decays on your side in this
sense
um and that has to do with like another
aspect that we haven't really discussed
yet which is or we've alluded to but
it's it's how uh especially with the
zero DTE options the fact that they're
expiring really governs um how they
behave
um but yeah basically if you know if
they're out of the money if they're
decaying
um then the obligation that they're
creating for the option seller is also
decaying and insofar as it's decaying
that option seller can buy back some of
their Hedges uh and insofar as they do
that it'll push the market right back to
where it was right back to the middle
yeah that's a I mean in that context
like I just historically am very bad at
trading range bound days I I'm okay at
spotting well I'm pretty good at
spotting the breakouts and you know like
Jess said keeping that risk lower and
riding that is much more my favorite way
to trade than trying to trade the range
but
um like you said John it's like you know
you make a good point about the fact
that your your levels are starting to
get fairly defined when you get into
those really really hard range days and
um you know you just have to play play
that tighter risk on the downside
tighter risk on the upside and try to
catch some reversions yeah I think it's
like you have a better like a structural
reason right for for the the ranges to
be defined versus like uh you know
momentum where it's not quite I mean
part of its structural you know maybe
like like the the closing of like debt
ceiling Hedges today causing this trend
day
um but it's not quite as as controlled
as as a range day
um but yeah I think it's also a
trade-off of like you know like decision
fatigue can also factor into its um and
stuff like that I mean personally sorry
go ahead no no yeah it's definitely a
personality thing I think I think what I
the only thing I really like about it is
just that I I feel more comfortable when
Thursday's sort of a structural like you
were saying sort of a pure theoretical
reason why this should work
um whereas uh and maybe I think some of
the slides that we have later kind of
start to solve this problem a little bit
but like when you're trading the
breakout you need more liquidity to keep
coming in in order to uh perpetuate the
move right um
keep throwing gas in the fire basically
and a lot of times that can dry up
exactly exactly
um oh that's actually a pretty decent
segue yeah I was gonna say
um
so I guess we can probably talk about
the well we're not calling live oi
anymore right we're calling it zero DT
order flow yeah
um John you want you want to get into
this yeah yeah so we alluded to this
earlier which is that there's this
assumption that gexbot is making and it
works pretty well most of the time uh
that uh it's just literally taking
volume uh netting it out and then
multiplying it by the gamma of that
particular strike and uh you can kind of
infer from the price action while what's
going on here people adding to position
or people selling those positions and so
forth and regardless of what's going on
you can kind of infer that it's an
important level but something that we've
been wondering about for a really long
time and I think a lot of other people
out there have been wondering about is
um what would it be like if you could
see if you didn't have to make that 90
deception if you could see uh calls and
puts being bought and sold in real time
live with a high degree of accuracy and
I understand that to a Futures Trader
that might sound a little trivial
because you think about it and you're
like well Futures uh the Bida spread is
sufficiently narrow that it's okay okay
somebody hit the bid somebody hit the
ask it's pretty clear what is by volume
and what cell volume but with options
that's not the case because bid and ask
are pretty wide most transactions go uh
go through near the mid price
um and so
keeping a keeping track of of who's
buying and who's selling and essentially
how many open contracts there are at
each given strike at each given time is
actually a pretty substantial Enterprise
there have been a lot of people that
have kind of attempted this
um and most people try to essentially
say okay well was this transacted closer
to the bid or was it transacted closer
to the ask and that's sort of a I would
say a strategy or a thought process
that's derived from Futures type of
order flow but um what what uh me and
Jess what we've been working on for the
last while is to devise a method that
doesn't depend on the bid ask at all in
order to categorize order flow
um and the results are really really
cool
um and yeah I think I think is there
anything else that I should add to this
particular slide chess that I missed
I think that that's that covers it I
think I I because you know I had also
thought for a while like the traditional
you know bid ask spread looking uh or
classification was was enough
um
yeah and it makes I mean obviously like
it makes sense to think that way right
because as we have in front of us now
it's standard options chain right you're
looking at like where are these likely
being transacted and
um like you said John mid price is
pretty much assumed right so
yeah it's funny because like I you know
for the longest time I did think that
they were being transacted on either end
of the spread but then when you actually
look at the data and uh we had tweeted
about the the Ambrose paper that I
brought this up
um a little while ago but like when you
actually look at the data you know the
transactions are not really occurring uh
on either side and it's really hard to
like you can kind of categorize but like
okay if it's greater than the midpoint
then maybe it's offer side but it's not
quite robust enough yeah and you you end
up with a ton of volume that you just
can't categorize because it happened at
the mid and a lot of times that's most
of the volume of the day so it's like a
very substantial portion and you're left
with you're like Okay cool so I can
categorize I don't 60 70 percent of the
order flow let's say but then you know a
lot of times in order we'll go through
that's you know a thousand two thousand
Lots at least SPX that's transacted at
the mid and so sometimes those really
big orders which are at really crucial
moments of the day are coming through
and you don't know how to categorize
them or sometimes there there are buys
that are transacted and look like cells
and I mean we see this I know that um
people have used other services and
noticed this a lot uh where a lot of
times right if somebody's price
insensitive then they'll go to the other
side of the spread because they don't
care because they need something now
right
um and that just is not captured uh
properly by these bid ask types of
methods
yeah but yeah so we built something that
that does it a little bit better it's a
little more accurate and uh we've been
watching it for a bit and it's it's kind
of Jess is being humble it's it's a lot
more organized okay
two percent of the volume of a given day
is yeah
it's actually pretty good
okay okay okay fair enough
um but it's it's it's been weird man
like it like the stuff that we see is
not really what you would expect
um but on a level like the resulting
price action tends to make sense
um so here's here's one example this
happens
essentially happened yesterday
um but this was near the end of the day
and oh let me actually explain what what
this chart is so the right side chart
first yeah and then we can watch some
price action yes
um so this is the Howie habit is um the
puts are colored red and the calls are
colored green and then the center axis
is zero I'm sorry the scale is all kind
of up but um uh if if the bars
are on the right that means the that
volume of contracts so this purely
volume no no gamma yet
um was bombs and then if it's extending
to the left or if it's negative volume
then it's considered sold
so in this case we're seeing a very
large I think it was like 12 000 uh lots
of 4 200 puts sold and it's kind of you
know and and we're we're ranging so
right now premium on ES so this is an es
chart
um is about eight points I think
um so 4200 on SPX puts us at like 42 8
so 4208 on on ES and another another
thing to mention is Right would you
really be initiating a position like
that with us sitting at zero zero gamma
now that we've learned about all these
levels and stuff right right and we're
hovering right there at the start of
this clip yeah
[Music]
I mean not me as a tiny fish but you
know someone who's loading fold down in
the money yeah you know yeah we were
looking at this yesterday and we were
like what on Earth are they doing
yeah and just so everyone knows this is
literally yesterday that this was from
because we're recording this on the
first of June
yeah it's just like I don't know I I
guess it's a way of a very specific way
of expressing expressing directional
bias or whatever but it's just not
something that I I ever would have
expected you know like if I was
expecting a rally I would have thought
that someone would load up and like out
of money calls or something but this is
just the very popular way again like
yeah if you have the capital this is a
better way to express that opinion
simply because fall is going to die as
we rally so right yeah it's a lot of
times what's crazy about it is that we
watch this option chain and we see stuff
that ends up making sense and yet as we
see it it's just not what we're used to
because it's let me just put it this way
like the big money plays different
yeah they play really different
I think it's people who are a lot
smarter than us probably with a lot more
money you know so
Story of My Life
um yeah and another thing to mentioned
is so yeah we mentioned the Amber's
paper and that tweet because they also
had noticed how using these sorts of bid
ass methods were particularly good at
doing this and they suggested a
different way of doing it
um and they also noticed uh and
published in their paper on zero DTE
that it seems like a lot of zero DP
action is actually option selling and
that's exactly what we've been seeing
um most zero DT options have been sold
and they're just premium collecting
strategies just like another way it's
like a yield farming on a day-to-day
basis with options that makes sense I
mean I I wouldn't think that without
reading that of course but if you think
about it now in the context of it you
know like you said John the people who
have the money are making that play to
collect the premium and if I mean Heck
if this goes then you know which I'm
based on the action we all know what's
gonna happen but
um and yeah that person's looking pretty
good right now yeah it's interesting
because like people you know we'll see
very far out of the money options so
like I think today we saw like 42 30
calls being short pretty early on and
even though like the direction of of the
the yield farming would suggest like an
opposite direction that we would move
away from that strike
um typically we kind of just navigate
towards it
um like we gravity we we get pulled
um I I was never really uh like I I know
about Max Payne but I never really read
into it
um but it seems to make the case for
like you know people are opening these
large positions and then we press
towards where they get most threatened
by its
um
yeah I still know what to make of it
I mean it's it's been completely
changing the way that we think about
think about markets and it's possible
that for instance like we've talked
about it but like it's possible that Max
Payne one of the reasons that it hasn't
seemed to work very well is because
um so many options are transacted and
today that the oi or volume numbers that
you have just don't reflect the actual
interest that's left so that you don't
actually know what the Max Payne is by
the end of the day yeah that makes sense
too because it's just you know you're
kind of sitting there head scratching
well not with this but
um like you said John you don't really
know and so you're kind of going back to
you know technical analysis and then
intraday you're able to use a tool like
this to start to gather it but you know
overnight you're kind of probably just
sitting there like all right
um you know it's one of the important
levels yeah
exactly
Jess how long is this uh
yeah it does make sense
but yeah sorry
yes then we start to break right I mean
this this is actually really cool to see
so whoever this is that's loaded up with
these 4200 puts
also another thing to I just want to
mention that all the other strikes are
moving right it's like people are
transacting all the time it's just that
everything's dwarfed by that once more
than 200 strikes yeah so for instance
They just added to the 4205s there
um just in the last little skip that
Jasper did
um yeah so they're adding to the calls
as those short puts are there and as
we're moving up
um and then now that we're consolidating
they're sort of like adding taking them
away adding taking them away
also it seems like it's a lot less
um active than I I would have thought
you know typically we'll see these large
positions being opened and then there's
some you know there are fluctuations
going on but it's like the everything
has been mostly set and you know whoever
is transacting these typically let
things just play out over the course
that's interesting interesting
so they're either very confident or
they're hedging in some other vehicle
probably Futures yeah yeah
that's that's usually the answer a lot
of times we'll see something and they'll
be like what the hell is that and then
and then I'll be like Jasper I think I
think this is the Futures that like I
think they they uh they're playing
somewhere else um well we'll see I don't
I still don't know if it's an illusion
or you know we'll see a very large
um number of contracts being opened and
then you can see kind of an immediate
like local reaction on ES
um it's like it's so close together in
timestamps that it's
maybe it's an illusion maybe it's not um
yeah yeah I mean that's it's really cool
though because you know if you're
someone who's reasonably first of all
who's got the capital put this type of
position on but also who's that well
funded Futures are liquid enough anyway
and so are the options but Futures is
easy enough to if you have that Capital
to kind of play in and pull off if you
need without leaving long-term exposure
that you're gonna have to cover up later
I mean all these funds have exposure all
over the place anyway but
um you know that makes sense that you
would see a correlation between some of
the larger spikes on this you know on
the Zero DT order flow tool and then the
Futures Market oh yeah and and the other
thing to mention at least in this case
with the 4200s themselves is and and
sometimes I mean this is why we're gonna
have different ways of depicting this
but you do need to know a little bit of
options theory in order to read this
sort of stuff so for instance those
4200s
um those are in deep in the money puts
which were sold or like pretty deep in
the money puts um so they don't have a
lot of sort of convexity risk that we
were talking about before right the
gamma on those is pretty low
um so essentially it's just kind of a
synthetic long
um
yeah so you can you start to put these
things together or a lot of times we'll
see for instance like that they've sold
puts and calls at the same strike and
that those are just holding so you can
tell oh there's a short straddle around
this one particular strike and we
usually gravitate towards that area and
just stay there and volatility
compresses when that happens it's really
really cool to see
yeah that's that's super interesting I
mean the breakdown of being able to see
that information is really cool
um and and John you mentioned you guys
have been working on this for for a long
while I think was your exact phrasing I
can't do that
well yeah we have some projects that we
were working on and then when Ambrose
came out with the paper we just were
like well you know what we might as well
start to yeah
lit a fire under us to be honest yeah
but yeah I'm actually really excited
about the next slides because right part
of doing this is also confirming that
the tool works and what's really hard
about confirming that the tool works is
that nobody will tell you there's no
information out there that especially if
because we're doing zero DTE and not one
DTE we don't know
um we can only see the transaction
history we can't see if something was
mod or sold um so we started to come up
with other types of Graphics to figure
out if what we have is actually working
um
and in addition to you know monitoring
whether we're categorizing all the
volume and in addition to um comparing
it to uh other a couple of other metrics
but these are the really sort of the
select things that we that we wanted to
show today
uh Jasper you wanna you wanna introduce
this one
yeah so this was I think was this the
4160 puts I think so but
um so we're just looking at ways of like
okay what if we measure net Deltas what
if we measure net net gamma
um of the contracts that are coming in
um and so this is a ratio of
net long gamma contracts over net short
contracts so long gamma uh as in terms
of um well bullish I guess you would say
yeah I was about to say bullish and
bearish so it's basically taking yeah so
on the one hand you have long calls and
short puts right so people who are
making bullish bets and on the other
side you have
um you have short calls and long puts
um and and then we're taking the gamma
of those two things and then we're
calculating this across the entire
options chain
yes across all the zero DTS okay here on
this day we we see this huge Spike uh
this isn't specific so this is 10 a.m
Eastern and it just it looks like
literally as you would think in like uh
like an auction right like a trend date
initiation where someone opens this
large position and then it sets the
context for the rest of the day
um and it's it's crazy because typically
right the when we say net gamma ratio it
usually hovers around the same level
which makes sense right because usually
uh bullish and bearish Gamma are quite
similar uh because because of put called
parity because of a lot of sort of
structural Market reasons and so when
you see somebody really shove and move
that ratio it means that something
happens so we don't know whether those
were long calls or short puts but we
know that somebody made a very
significant wager that elevated bullish
gamma at that point in time
yeah they had a really strong
directional bias wow and and so later in
the day you get this other Spike too
yeah yeah so it seems like both of these
are leading
um in this case two you know this looks
like either they screwed up or I'm still
not sure what to make of it um I think
in you know usually with how Trend days
work you have that initial drive and
then we have consolidation and then you
have continuation and it looks like
whoever this was they it might be a data
feed thing or they did look for that
continuation and then it did end up
failing so it's not like they're you
know it's not like they're um
they're they're perfect right
um but it's still it's still enough that
like there's such little noise relative
to when these spikes come in that
um it's hard not to see this direct
correlation between the underlying right
right and that could also be like that
Spike before the kind of pullback could
I mean you never know like the same
person might have added to that for a
second go you know yeah yeah so very
interesting
yeah um okay so we were coming up with
all sorts of different ways to basically
do this
um and this is not the ratio this is
literally just net gamma
um so it's uh
how do we put the stress it's like
literally I think this was we took all
what was that long gamma so it's looking
for convexity divided or subtract short
gamma so looking for a compression
I think that's what this one was
um
I'm trying to remember we end up we end
up having so many different
interpretations in that like it it gets
uh sometimes there's quite a few ways of
like of looking this you know but a lot
of this has been trying to turn like the
original tool into something that um
is more actionable like uh sure you know
I think that the the tricky thing with a
lot of this kind of um analysis is that
there's a tendency to want to you know
throw a whole bunch of charts at people
um you know give them as much analysis
as as possible and I think that that can
make it hard for a lot of people and
um at least with Geck spot like a lot of
it has been trying to drill it down to
something that's like uh more actionable
right like
um I understand the limitations of this
tool this tool is telling me something
um and then I get to make the decision
to you know how do I incorporate it
right versus the tool trying to make
um
uh certain decisions for me um yeah
which you know somehow is what everyone
thinks they need but in my experience
that's never the way to go right too
much information analysis paralysis
exactly like well this is the thing long
this is short but then we're looking for
a range expansion
um
Jasper I think I remembered and I think
you're right this one is literally it's
literally net gamma it's basically how
many people are long options gamma
versus short options
and so yeah yeah and so at the beginning
of the day you see people are trying to
sell options when which is exactly what
you know the Amber's paper noticed
um and they're trying to short you know
and this is this is behavior that we see
very very commonly it's basically people
who want to collect premium they often
short options at the beginning of the
day they take them off around you know
noon 2 p.m and then they try to uh get
long premium towards the end of the day
except that on this particular day we
started to sell off and we just continue
to sell off so you can see that people
are increasing their exposure they're
more long options into the end of the
day and then it Peaks right when we find
the bottom for the day
um
and then at that point people start to
sell options in other words a massive
wave of put selling comes in which is
that first leg down right there and then
it just continues into the end of the
day and then this expansion of gamma is
just right at the closing hour of the
day that just has to do with the fact
that
um
uh just like the way that gamma is
calculated means that because you have
all of these other uh when basically
when as time goes to zero gamma kind of
goes to Infinity for a very brief second
so that's why you see that massive
expansion into the end of the shark yeah
yeah
this one's a little bit easier to
understand this one's really cool
um this one and the next one
um this is literally just long Deltas
divided by short Deltas
um Delta ratio
um and then so here we we see this it's
like hovering around one ish or so and
then we have this massive uh long Delta
Spike that comes in
and then we see either reflexively or
you know they're going along the
underlying in general but we see this
this massive rally that occurs after the
spike has has happened in the zero GT
complex
I think that's one of the
I mean obviously everyone's looking for
leading indicators but um
um yeah it's yeah yeah it's good like
actionable right I mean
you know nothing's guaranteed obviously
in this business but you know anything
to kind of give you an actionable hey
this is what seems to be going on right
now it's like the options Market there's
so much reflexivity right it's like the
underlying moves in a way then the
option Market is like reacting to it and
so if there's a lot of difficulty in
separating the two or like trying to
kind of quantify where one starts and
the other one uh ends or something
um and then here too okay well I mean
this one's kind of fun because this is
literally today earlier today so that's
why the full chart is incomplete because
we didn't re-graph it later but you can
also see you can see the initiation same
as that other slide where all of a
sudden that net Delta ratio spikes means
a lot of people bought a lot of calls
for sold a lot of puts whichever uh read
at that moment and then we saw it again
before the next Spike yeah so again
these aren't necessarily the tools that
we want to be releasing
um but these are things that we're using
to test all of our assumptions uh and
make sure that
um our understanding of you know how
people are taking on or taking off risk
corresponds to the movement that we see
in the underlying and then part of the
end game but I think maybe just maybe
you'll speak more to this is actually
incorporating this zero DT order flow a
live tracking of which contracts are
open into gexbot itself to eliminate
some of the naive assumptions of the
original model
yeah that that is definitely like the
goal I think it's also you know trying
to really shave this down into something
that like can be immediately
um usable uh try to like maintain
Simplicity
um but also like still be actionable
yeah
um
yeah definitely like actionable
um you know information and simple
actionable information is even better
right
uh if you have to think too much then
you're probably dead that's what an old
Floor Trader told me so
if you're really thinking about you
should probably just exit you should
probably yeah yeah I've I've tried to
live by that one so flat is the position
yeah is a position yeah yeah absolutely
very cool
um well that's awesome I I definitely
appreciate you guys sharing like the
research you're doing behind this too I
know early the beginning you mentioned
um a lot of what you've been doing now
is the research side of things but it's
cool to get a look into it and how
you're you're plotting this out to see
you know how everything's interacting
and what you're building is is working I
mean I can tell you that's probably more
than a lot of people do when they put a
tool out right
um testing these assumptions and things
is they crucial
well I think I think it would be to be
honest it would be super scary to put a
tool out that yeah we weren't willing to
use ourselves
um
and and to be honest like we've been uh
at least I know the other day Jess like
you were you were using it quite
actively like you used an indication of
some uh some calls coming in to get long
I think yeah uh it was the uh I think it
was the 4160 put short that came in like
this day I saw that because it was just
like like what like 10 points out of
money puts just got short massively like
it's hard to not take that trade uh yeah
and then as far as a risk perspective I
mean you know in terms of Market context
your risk I imagine can still be pretty
easily defined right when you had to
initiate the position because you're
looking for a move and if that move
doesn't happen you can haven't stopped
somewhere below or I plan to get out
below that yeah oh yeah everything is
always always within the context of like
volume profile still like um the auction
you know making sure that I'm not just
like blindly you know piling into
something
um yeah it's easy I mean even though
right even though SPX is heavily
correlated to es is heavily correlated
to spy
Etc right like these instruments they
all they still move differently there's
a difference between initiating an
options trade which is what I prefer to
do uh and trying to trade Futures based
off of this so even if we recognize that
it's super important and it influences
the Futures Market really heavily that
doesn't mean that all the technicals of
the Futures Market stopped applying
right by no means right right
I think what's tricky too is sometimes
like you'll see like we'll see someone
short like a huge amount of puts right
and it gives kind of this directional
bias but then if they're so out of the
money it's not like you just can't enter
a position based off of that like in in
es like you're not really wanting to go
short to go to that level because like
now your bias is kind of bullish but
it's not like you can go long because
it's so out of the money you you'll be
facing like 20 30 points of drawdown
which is not remotely responsible
um so there's a lot of like it's still
kind of tricky combining something like
this with the with the pure Deltas based
um I think yeah I think but but on the
other hand though right like when we
were talking you guys like to trade
those Trend days and we're talking about
how sort of price just kind of
consolidates into the upper end of the
range and just squeezes itself right
against a gamma node before exploding
higher and we have been just seeing that
over and over again and we honestly we
do not know what they're doing Ian but
like they just keep selling calls and
then getting squeezed and then they just
keep adding to the calls and so we'll
see price consolidate like I think today
it was 42.30 price will or 4220
um but price will just consolidate into
that part of the range and then they
keep adding short calls adding short
calls
um price jumps up they all get squeezed
they all fail and they just keep rolling
back down
so I mean some of these we showed you
guys an example of you know some traders
that are pretty smart getting into those
short 4200s before a big rally uh
there's also a lot of Traders out there
that do stuff on SPX who don't seem to
be particularly smart or they maybe have
a different time frame than I'm aware of
but um yeah it's kind of amazing yeah
well it's kind of funny too because it's
like if there's zero DTE you know what's
your time frame or what else are you in
that you're putting on yeah I was just
trying to be generous
well it's probably like you know you
have like so much Capital then it's like
well all right I'll punt some short
calls here like yeah yeah
I mean part of that too you know like
even institutions and large participants
right even still there's that how did we
end up here and we're probably going
down so I'm just going to add to this
this
and then they still end up wrong right
so yeah
we'll be human right that's right well
cool
um
I didn't really have anything else you
guys wanted to add here I mean you've
shared a ton of info and I definitely
appreciate
um putting the videos together too
because having that context on the
platform is awesome and people love to
see you know stuff in the action of
especially our listeners the EMA s p of
course
um
but definitely happy to have you on and
if you have anything you want to add
feel free
um
oh yeah
I think that's basically it for us I
know that like you know gamma is like a
really complicated topic
um I think you know it kind of requires
a lot of like fundamental math stuff
which in the end of the day I feel like
is not
necessary or it's like you have to learn
these things and then forget about the
forget about them when it comes to
actually trading because you can't be
like thinking about all these freaking
derivatives while you're trying to make
a decision right
um but like
yeah it's it's fun to come on to like a
platform with you and like be able to
talk a little bit about this you know I
think there's a lot more to cover
um but I think yeah that's essentially
um the gist of it but yeah so uh again
my name is Joss
um you can find our tweets at all gamma
all day
um we also have a website uh kexpot.com
where you can find the uh the image
outputs and then if you want you can
subscribe and check out the real-time
version uh on our Twitter is also our
Discord uh I'll link to our Discord so
you can come there and ask us questions
if you have any
yeah and I'm I'm John again and I have a
I have a podcast that's there and we
just basically get into some of the
nerdier stuff uh sometimes we do a
little less nerdy stuff and there's some
fundamentals videos up there but I think
I think overall all I really want to say
is that um yeah we've been working
really hard on this stuff it's an insane
amount of fun
um and yeah we hope that people will
stay tuned uh as we start to release
some of this and sort of amplify the
discussion uh Beyond just just us right
we want we want to get as many people
looking at these things as possible I
mean you guys definitely got me looking
at all of it so count me in there
thank you